>>> FOR 15 YEARS THE PENCILS FOR
PROMISES ORGANIZATION HAS
IMPACTED A QUARTER OF A MILLION
STUDENTS AROUND THE WORLD.
THE CHARITY HAS BUILT NEARLY 190
SCHOOLS AND DELIVERED NEARLY
1,000 WATER FILTERS TO PEOPLE IN
NEED.
WORLD FAMOUS RAPPER LIL JOHN HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH PENCILS FOR
PROMISE FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
NOW.
WE HAVE HIM HERE.
YOU KNOW IT IS A SPECIAL DAY
WHEN WE HAVE CHAIRS HERE --
>> I WAS GOING TO BRING THAT UP.
>> ON CNN "NEWS CENTRAL."
THIS IS SO OUTRAGEOUSLY
WONDERFUL.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE CHAIRS.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> AND THE WORLD KNOWS YOU AS
THE KING OF CRONK, YOU KNOW IT
IS SERIOUS WHEN YOU CAN GET
CHAIRS ON THE DANCE FLOOR HERE.
>> AND YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN
DOING WORK FOR ABOUT 10 TEN
MINUTE, AND THEN I WENT TO A
CHARITY EVENT AND I WAS INSPIRED
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
HAD BUILT SCHOOLS IN GHANA AND
LAOS AND ANOTHER COUNTRY THEY
BUILT SCHOOLS IN, BUT THE
COUNTRY OF THE SCHOOLS THAT HAD
BUILT THE SCHOOLS, AND SEATED
PLACES OF THE -- YOU KNOW, THE
VIDEO OF THE PRESENTATION OF THE
SCHOOLS, AND THE KES FACE TIS,
AND IT AND THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE BUILDING SCHOOLS IN GHANA,
AND I WANTED TO BUILD TWO
SCHOOLS RIGHT AWAY.
SO I KNEW WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
WE RAISED MONEY, AND I BUILT TWO
SCHOOLS IN GAUNHAGHANA.
>> SO IN 2018, YOU BROKE GROUND.
WHAT IS THAT LIKE WHEN YOU ARE
THERE AND YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING BIG, A
CHANCE AT AN EDUCATION.
>> IT IS LIKE MIND BLOWING WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SAY, WELL, DON'T HAVE
OR THAT, AND THEN YOU GO INTO
THE VILLAGES WHERE THEY DON'T
HAVE RUNNING WATER, AND THEY ARE
LIVING IN HUTS, AND YOU KNOW, I
SAW THE SCHOOLS THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF THELE SCHOOLS THAT WE
HAD BEFORE WE CAME IN AND GOT
INVOLVED, AND THERE WAS LIKE NO
AIR CONDITIONING, AND LIKE A
TREE, THEY WERE DOING THE
CLASSES UNDER A MANGO TREE.
LIKE OUTSIDE IN AFRICA.
IT IS HOT.
ANIMALS ARE WALKING BY, AND THE
KIDS ARE EASILY DISTRACTED.
TO GO IN AND SEE THAT, IT JUST
BLEW MY MIND, AND NOW I CAN HELP
THESE CHILDREN GO ON THE DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO BECAUSE
OF THE POWER OF EDUCATION.
>> AND IT HELPED A VILLAGE.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW, I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE THAT YOU ARE
DOING, BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT JUST
IN THE RAP GAME AND NOW YOU
DOING A SHOW, AND WHAT IS IT
THAT LIL JOH
N WANTS TO DO?
>> LIL JON WANTS TO DO WHAT?
IT IS A HOME IMPROVEMENT, AND
MYSELF AND TWO OTHERS GO AND
RE-DO SHOWS.
>> I HAVE ONE YOU CAN DO.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BUDGET.
>> AND HERE YOU ARE BREAKING
GROUND TO BUILD SCHOOLS IN GHANA
AND NOW YOU ARE REVAMPING
PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
AND WHAT THE HECK GOT YOU DOING
THIS?
>> WELL, I HAD TO DO MY OWN
HOME.
I WAS IN L.A. LIVING, AND I WAS
STILL HAVING MY HOME IN ATLANTA.
A PIPE BURST AND WATER RUNNING
FOR A WEEK, AND I HAD TO GUT MY
HOUSE BACK, AND I WENT TO TWO
CONTRACTORS AND THEN GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS, I WANTED
TO PUT MY HOUSE BACK TOGETHER IN
A WAY BETTER WAY THAN BEFORE.
ONE DAY I WAS WATCHING THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT SHOWS TRYING TO GET
INSPIRATION, AND I WAS WATCHING
ANITRA AND I ASKED IF SHE WOULD
BE DOWN WITH HELPING ME ON MY
HOME, AND WHEN WE WERE DONE, HER
HUSBAND SAID THAT YOU WORK
REALLY GOOD TOGETHER, AND
SECOND, YOUR DESIGNS ARE INSANE
AND YOU NEED TO DO A SHOW
TOGETHER.
SO WE PUT TOGETHER TO SHOW, AND
HERE WE ARE WITH "LIL JON WANTS
TO DO WHAT